a muscular looking front end and a
striking air scoop are not the sort of
accessories you'd expect to find on a
station wagon but they're a perfect fit
with a Subaru levorg the name levorg is
a combination of the words legacy the
card replaced plus revolution and
touring auto tester and rate Zimmerman
says a wagon is great for vacation
driving these days they look more sporty
than they used to like the four-wheel
drive Subaru levorg it's practical too
you just pull back the cover and then
you can reconfigure the luggage
compartment to meet your needs
important frost on and with sits in bits
in Buster once you've removed the middle
section and the side panels you can
store the cover in the base put the side
panels back and you're good to go
this way you don't have to leave the
compartment cover at home when you go on
vacation it's a really practical design
so let's load some stuff the trunks
capacity is 522 litres and it's 104
centimeters deep so there's plenty of
room Andre says the last thing he's
going to load is our camera tripod bag
it wouldn't fit into most trunks because
it's so long you're - it's a little long
but that's no problem with a touch of a
button the problem is soft the back seat
folds down to make even more room and
were ready to go that's not father
the levorg is design is based on the
Subaru Impreza but it's a cut above that
model the levorg sells for just under
twenty nine thousand euros complete with
four-wheel drive and automatic
transmission Andre really likes the
levorg suspension it's quite stiff you
feel some of the unevenness in the road
he says and larger bumps are best
avoided
otherwise it could get a bit
uncomfortable but because the suspension
is stiff the levorg is quite low to the
ground giving it great stability and has
a relatively low center of gravity so it
can handle even sharp curves easily kind
of evoke existing cool from the vibe of
it Andre has a minor complaint about the
CVT transmission he says it causes
problems while he's driving through a
curve he takes his foot off the gas
while driving into the curve but then
he's coming out of it and tries to speed
up the car takes a few seconds to react
the levorg is available in three
customised models the car has a power
output of 125 kilowatts and can move
from 0 to 100 kilometers an hour in 8.9
seconds it's got a sporty look and feel
but Andre feels Subaru could make a few
improvements here
let's me a bomb if you'd like to see
more choices for the engine and
transmission right now all you can get
is a 1.6 liter engine and the CVT anti
says he'd welcome a bigger more powerful
engine and the manual transmission on
the other hand he likes the way that you
can customize the levorg interior the
color we're in right now has the red and
black color option says Andre there's a
little red stripe in the steering wheel
so you can see when you're driving
straight ahead
it's the macaws easy to understand clock
gotta see it and you've got nice
Alcantara covering on the wheel to
Fritzi focus their food it's little
things like that that put the levorg
interior closer to that of a luxury
model like a BMW or an Audi Audi off
stag busted in home and get so what does
Andre think of the Subaru levorg overall
as a firm assistant he says it's a great
car for travel but Subaru could change a
few things to make it a sporty or
vehicle still overall it's a very
practical car